what oh hello my name is earl bebo i'm a
research scientist from always signs of
progress and when you and also a result
party person and Holly today i will
discuss a recent work on visual
expression of data tickle i wanna NYC
text data you see why I make the tools
we develop these texts Elise so leave it
to Mike Trout family is a research in
data visualizations and analysis focused
our interactive applications for doing
on high performance computing and
skeptics say like those are great as
well so the things that I do a lock with
a system demo programming so I'm see
person I loved watching to see what I
shall do not pack how to be honest and
those are the two language I used see if
I can a second I love Python and I was
awarded the quality character of this
world which is a system for managing
problems and people flow so the entire
book was written in Python and we have
our experience fun experience with my
cutie mark bath wave of how to wrap
visualization with me to carry some
stuff like that and I could have talked
about these trousers and I was curious
in this talk but I guess
is a big cities of an area so let's talk
about big city and so there will not be
a lot of Python stuff of my talk but i
will say how we want to tie the Python
later so bear with me since we talked
about our science so let's give an
introduction to cut so custom is a new
research center only for two years and
we're focusing on collecting common data
and make use of that data to really need
to win the series and develop new
techniques to improve the live of the
season it is a multi-sector
collaborations we're not doing this a
long way so we have a lot of connection
to agencies silly agency like dota ypd
fire department where we will collect
the babies in their data for analysis
and we also a multidisciplinary the
organization because we're pulling a
researchers from all of the domains like
super generic emotionally
all those and how goal is to really
develop new processing makes me laugh
and then applying those techniques to
article feta and we also train the
student to create if you know in all the
science we the word trace is a little
bit over statement which is pretty much
introduced on the big data analytics we
with that they use the mask program is a
point incorporated but they are all very
good so we are happy done so why big
ceilings so the thing is that a cutie
percent of the world populations is
living in seeds nowaday nap number blue
price to eighty percent in 40 years in
fact in North America we already have
people in area right and we're going to
go to ninety percent in 2050 so the
cities are where be sure to consume and
you know and all those economy after
this happen so of course we always say
that cities are the costs our problem
but when you pro series they will do is
calculate in like how to do
transportation housing pollution etc
like that put them so where we redefine
our solutions it is pretty much that
because only in public area we do have
infrastructure to collect the data and
have the data that we do instrumental
our research on sealed so based on those
data we can really mess with more
efficient sustainable and there's a
couple of good examples on how big
using the past I'm sure it here this is
some success stories so one bunch of
ways and one knows about this right
pretty much this is app will let you see
it first off and tell you how long the
bus going to come we did just a quickie
model model and by said that time he
will suggest let's go to the next time
instead of a silicate wait right and so
do it by doing that the writers also
have a feeling that they wait left and
so more healthy so this app was a big
success because they make use of
historical data of a bus first time in
the past including will occur in verses
locations and they have very good
predictive models to suggest the right
time or the bus coming next and because
of that you know ninety percent that the
increases satisfaction from writers
really increase why is 78 people want
more and so let's say all this is thanks
to like take over data advances on the
back end because we thought that if you
click something wrong by a walk from my
starter next up and a bus pass fight
ended we screw up the entire thing this
is really carefully make success so what
another example is with the mayor's
office completa analytics and the legal
version data so back in the first Piper
start
hello
okay so so so illegal conversion is that
when you take a unit on an apartment in
New York and try to split the up to as
many sub smaller units and now you try
to increase the number of tenants right
number of people's leading that as many
as time tense as I supposed to so this
really caused a fire hazard and because
all of the extending cord you know the
hanging everywhere is blocking the exit
exit door for example and in 2005 it was
actually two firefighters died because
they try to help people in these house
so this was posing as a very serious
problem to the cities and Mike flowers
who was the head of the NYC motor at the
time now he's an urban science fellow
that cusp he's really one is homeless
problem by using big data Sue's the
problem is the root of this problem is
that about 25,000 illegal conversion
reports or complains every year in New
York City but they only have 200
inspectors to do the jobs so they go out
they check every single place and if the
place is really severe very serious
issues with fire hazard we will issue a
vacatur order but the things that when
they come out there are many places that
don't really need that attention yet it
is very very simple like illegal
conversion it wouldn't really cause a
fire hazard yet why there's those places
I haven't touched yet really much more
urgent need more priority so did so the
flowers group they really look through
all the data they try to put a priority
into these the orders up where this
inspector should go first to check for
the places so what they did is that they
take the data from 19 different agencies
from late taxes foreclosure proceedings
and you know like like ambulance on
those records and combined with the five
years of file data to see which place we
likely have a chance to causing a fire
and would really have some real
accidents and by doing that they really
increase a hit rate from thirty percent
to seventy percent which means like
whenever like seven times out of 10 when
the inspector go out to a place and
check for the place it is really like a
serious issue of a kid orders which
means that they choose a priority right
much better so this really improve the
safety of a city
so so these two are really two success
story but they are very few and did a
very few and far between right because
analyzing the urban data is really
difficult because the series is complex
it has different components like
infrastructure which is bridges road up
tall etc and environment which is just
the pollutions the weather all these are
factors and especially people they how
they move you know the mobilities they
have nutritions in order to really
analyze the open data we need the data
from all these components so that is why
there's a lot of initiative lino and
what's the open data or data golf make
this data available but the things that
in order to really solve this we need a
domain expert and doom an expert when
they look at these no variety complex
later they really don't know what to do
with that because it required a lot of
expedition is it really a scalability
issues so why is it hard so scalability
yes but not only for computations
scalability scalability problem in
competitions is challenging of course
but it's something we've been dealing
with forever right because we have
simulation data as in physics chemistry
bio since like 30 years four years who
knows and is always much larger than
your machine so there's a wait
techniques in distributed computing
power that basis that you know we've
been working on it's in the past so it's
challenging it's not new and now we have
had do we just do very easy thing just
put more machines let's also bit more
those are not the best way to solve it
at the same whether we can do that right
so that the real challenging part is the
people scalability in the people in
order to transform the data into some
good knowledge some knowledge that will
be useful need to go through a very
complex process that require a lot of
expertise in different domains could be
diagonal provenance data management
algorithms or visualizations and we can
fit this into a single domain expert a
single person or small group of people
and in addition no the road from data to
knowledge is not a straight line it's
really it's really just a big messy rope
right because you need to tweak these
together how to integrate you know data
measurement to visualization to our gems
such thing like that and if you do
something wrong is messed up the
thing so this is a problem with
analyzing urban data but not it doesn't
matter is a big or small it's always
there because it's the complexity of the
data is that really the size of the data
so uh so but if we notice that note this
box we can fit into a person we can
really encapsulate all those into our
tools are some techniques that a person
can use so this is really the way that
our research group will really wanna
heading to right we want to be scalable
tools I scare both techniques that make
it's very easy for domain expert domain
scientists to use the tools with all the
machine learning a package already data
measurement package already they just
use a tool to do their jobs whatever
they good at so they don't really need
us in the loop anymore which we need to
ship it to them and they will you know
and we don't require them to have a CS
training background they came social
scientists government employees are
citizens and these two should be able to
look at historical data current later
and try to help them to be no some
knowledge about the futures I've tried
to really improve city so to illustrate
this I'm going to discuss talk about one
hour recent work in the tax v's a
particular in the taxi data so probably
already heard about accidentally enough
right so let me just summarize so taxi
is a heaven collected since 2008 from a
TLC texting lived in commissions every
time we enter a taxi that we recall our
location pick up and drop off along with
the durations other attributes like you
know like how far you went how many
people in the car and how much you pay
for fair and tips etc oh so the taxis
are really just transaction no records
they're not really sensors but however
however they have spatial temporal
components they can act as a sensor for
the cities and really show us how the
city leaves right so a number of
questions we can ask for us about what
is the average trip time from midtown to
airports during weekdays that can really
tell us like the traffic conditions we
can ask thy way out the popular night
spot during on a monday night show
wednesday night this could be easy Oh as
you know human activities so all this
question can be really anxious with just
taxi data so if you look and also add
story and also at the macro and micro
level right so if you look at the plot
on the top so this is a taxi data at the
micro level
microwave so I'm plotting the number of
trips per day for the entire years up to
us in eleven and two thousand twelve so
if we seize we can please see right away
there's a big dip during August 2011 and
so a big dip in october two thousand
twelve so these are really when the city
has no sign of life so this makes sense
because those are when the hurricane hit
New York rise there was no activities at
all during that time and we can look at
Christmas for example like all way to
the two December's we just stay home and
we'll go out so then the cities is
really empty so that's really a sensor
at a micro level at a micro level so if
I'm blasting the taxi trips on the maps
like this so the blue dots at the pickup
and orange dots at the drop-off and I'm
putting in four hours on may first 2011
so by looking through the hours you can
clearly see that at 8am the entire six
evony was blocked indicating that there
was some event going on there and
actually there was the fiber O'Toole's
happening during that that's Sunday and
they really plug the entire road so to
these later I could really tell us more
about like the microphone like what
really happening at a particular place
and particular time so the challenge
with exploring this data is of course
the size the complexity as well so so
during the five years they had collected
five hundred thousand trips per day so
it's add up almost I heard million trips
for an entire period and idiot us notice
right this plot on the top very simple
but it took us 20 minutes to using
Python code the scan through the entire
data on a single laptop to produce a
plot 20 minutes of course we also run on
Hadoop as well also use Python streaming
it took two minutes but we use a 1000
course which is a lot of resources so in
order to do make this such a plot this
is a lot of processing power needed this
is really a challenge if you give this
to a to a domain expert they won't be
able to run it on the environment you
have the code expertise or they know
that the tools are the resource to do
that so so anyway so the government
policymakers a sign
I really unable to due process this
later and we talked to the TRC and the
DoD folks directly the agency not just
like someone at our place so the data is
a complex because they have spatial
temporal components not only one but two
pick up and drop off in order to queries
or extract least information it's really
a challenge I would totally bit later
why is the challenge and along that we
have about 12 attributes of other things
to index in the database of course too
many slices from you to select as well
so our goal is to be a tool that can
have a very useful interface easy for
scientists to explore this data
interactively query the data as well
that is that active is true so that's
that's this is just a summary the list
of features we have in the tools but in
separate there are two things important
here that we have a set of visual
operations that the scientists are the
domain experts can really click things
on the screen draw something on the map
and select the data and it drill down
with unseeded resolve with plus
visualizations the other thing is would
be very fast and efficient database
back-end that can really serve the data
in the interactive speed right so we
without saying too much into this I can
show that the actual demo
so this is video but I
you see this my console I do programming
here
so this is a tax evasion applications so
just and we said all of data are sitting
on my laptop then hi three years will
have previous rest in 10 sorry present 9
11 and 12 on my laptop it takes about 30
gigabytes of data so everything is
running locally except the map we try to
map from google map so that's why we
need internet but other than that
everything is locally render locally and
processed locally so i'm showing here is
a career for one hour of taxi data so
the blue dots are showing the pick up
and read as for showing your drop off
right so if I so this is showing that
the micro example here if I doing this
I'm just passing through the hours you
can see right at 8am then I is 67
English plus all these are done in real
time will query and then Italian bit
they get back normal again the sleeping
go for more data this week before we go
for a week up data I can just put in at
a time constraint here and pick queries
quite a few of data so at the bottom so
these are so light the plaster that we
saw before at a macro level so we have
like the number of trips per time you
can't really see the activities of the
taxi to an entire week and that's always
it did you know at around less a 43 40
pipe or p.m. every day that's happening
because no that is it so that is a time
when oh sorry that's the time when the
taxi has to go back to the garage all
right so they don't really want to pick
up the passenger unless you go their way
so this is why on the deal happening at
4pm okay all right so one google one
while quick features that we put in this
is a application is the ability to query
space which mean people can really draw
on the maps
so what I'm just lit there it is i query
all the trip starting from the West
Village and this happened in real time
so now the plus only show the trips
during in that regions and if i want to
show more files about all the trips from
Upper East Side I can do another one so
now in the plus you can see the
comparison between two different regions
they are actually two different queries
one that's starting from the herbicide
the other one starting from the West
Village and you see in the plot or B
there's more pick up in the upper side
and the west village during this week
and if we want more restriction ok so do
this which showing only showing me trip
starting from West Village not going to
up inside it's not the plot is change so
the ability to query the data set based
on the regions in the application is
really helpful for for the scientists at
the OT and TLC
I've got back to number one so instead
of showing that we can also show it maps
so instead of showing points we shall
show them hit map so this is showing
that the hot spot to the week right oh
sorry that's it just show pickups right
there so these are really hot hot spot
of the city's you can see like there's a
more pickups happening on the avenue
that on the street through this hit map
and these are really the place not
having a lot of traffic is Penn
station's water already and grand
central stations which is a very obvious
but these just to confirm the hypothesis
so these are tool can be used to know
exploring the data another thing is that
so now i can create the entire year
worth of data inside the tool too so let
me show that
so just that it's an entire year worth
of beta 180 million point has show up on
no in this heat map and and so actually
in our data structure we treat each of
the point as a chopper trip as a point
in hyperspace anyway so so some
interesting thing with this is that if i
put here 365 so look at how fast the
plot is generated so instead of doing
just a simple script a linear scrape
that took no 20 minutes to generate this
plot in our in our system it's done in
real time this is because we do also
like you know multi-core as well but we
still have some technology under the
hammer flow which is a parallel flow
architecture to run this task anyway so
this charity exact same plot as we saw
before 2011 this is aaron and this is
Christmas is the thanksgiving and there
are also a number of interesting queries
for example if i want to reverse courage
if you want to show is that up know like
where the capsule when they landed
airport i can do so i'm selecting all
trip starting from the warrior
and JFK so these showing the trip
starting from those regions but now I
want do the reverse query I want to see
where they go drink this and type here
at time I can select the destinations
and do say queries so now show me the
hit map of where all the trips starting
from description went to right and if we
really normalize this like that so di
really the true hotspot up cities when
the visitor come to the airport and they
go to this place any why gasps wait a
spacer
sorry moment so yes it's okay yeah it's
close but I think that they did not
exactly go to mom I guess they go to the
one next to moma which is a hilton so
all these are hotels right yeah yeah so
these are lady the sheraton right here
and now here we have the Marriott and
interconnect oh so so it makes sense
they come to the airport they go back to
their hotel and then before they go to
different places I'm sorry yeah probably
I'm sorry so this is a number of things
here right so the rendering engines of
the hit maps are done in OpenGL and the
interface had any cutie and the maps
we're using a JavaScript embedded
browser for the maps of google maps
inside so pretty much with Drago maps at
the bottom and we do all mushy on top
yes and this part I would yes oh it's
cut off of sorry yeah also I've been
doing sorry so i'll be using these to
select like destination and you know and
then okay so it's a magic off the screen
I guess yeah okay all right so so we can
all see that there's are more trips
going to LaGuardia then to chef K in any
case and so these two I can look at
multiple attributes at sometimes yeah
probably so so forcibly it's time
showing that number of trips I can show
like the tips of my own you know like
the demise or how every speed or the
plots not just a single attributes but
they're entirely upper 14 attributes and
then and that the d-o-t they using this
by export is after this data selection
like an export for do further analysis
by doing this so as an export function
can export to CSV mudblood my mother
sorry my lap is etcetera okay so so
that's pretty much the demo Dan so let
me go back to d thank you
myself some hopes
okay so just to just to recap the
feature is up the tool right so if we
don't have a visual operations in order
to query such a trip line you know show
me all trips going from town square the
chroma see you have to rise very very
tedious sequel comment a statement like
this on the left you must know your
attributes name you must know like your
time and what is that the table name and
how to define a regions if you use both
squares you have to really define a
polygon of the town square and that is
not easy so so outdoors pretty much let
users select the data slides directly on
the do I go through a spatial temporal
attribute constraints so for example
here the time is specified by the top
panel and then the spatial by just
drawing the region there and in the end
we have like the datas result show unify
with color lines matching and we can
select regions by pretty five polygons I
think I forgot to show this well pretty
much like we can load a predefined set
of polygons with zip code neighborhood
and we can just do selection right there
all we can do free selection doesn't
know which I showed and we can group
them together we mention like a show
like creeps starting from both airports
at same time as a single query instead
of two queries right and here's that
selecting time there are so that the
future is not a tab that can do
recurrent am patterns instead of
selecting time by just a continuous
region period we can do like all tuesday
on sep tember 2011 for example so those
queries and again we can do like an
attribute selection even on the plus you
can also select the region's you want
interest and they will narrow down the
number of trips returned to them to the
scientist alright so so these are the
class then so let's say these are
spatial temporal data and there's also
work we fall from perk words as she
defied the triad the query triad which
means like in order to support
interactive exploration of spatial
temporal data you need to support this
class of queries when where and showing
what or when was showing we're like no
we're at the hot spot in manhattan in
weekends like leaving that the when the
time and the attribute what a look
Young is a constraint you know where it
is so our system support all three types
of class of curry classes and more we
can do when and go to the other two so
something like that and to make it
simpler so so he just is showing example
so this is just I think it's got a bit
of it under here so when is for the time
the maps beware and the what is for ways
for the map and then the what is for the
attributes and composing the queries can
selecting really on the maps link them
together etc here's some examples that
can be done with the tools like showing
all the trips going from little
Manhattan to you know to the two
airports but now comparing them side by
side so we can have two windows in the
same tools and sometimes and if you look
at a scatter plot at the bottom it's
showing that the red does I'll go to JFK
right so is showing that on the Monday
from 3pm to 5pm the time that text from
lower manhattan to the airport is much
increased compared to sunday it's also
make sense this is just very no trivial
sorry very obvious like conclusion
because uh weirdest traffic during that
time Oh week so this is just another use
case we can select the neighborhoods in
comparing between them like that's
almost no taxi stuff in the Harlem so
they'd really underserved as showing in
the little bottom after so here is one
example that we can really show the
house and he was recovered in Manhattan
and Brooklyn so sandy hit in New York in
I think on Monday no October 29 and then
and then just to raise after that they
gone but if you look at the Brooklyn
they recover pretty fast right away on
the Wednesday 31st but if you look at my
Hannon only the upper part get recover
the lower part my hair done is still
really empty there's no activities there
until saturday so because there was a
really huge power outage in the lower
Manhattan when it's only happened in New
York so they'd really slowly recover
just something trivial guys just showing
the hot spot so so using this tool you
know where to go to certain time I guess
avoid sudden crowd so let's go go back
to that there really let's see the entry
behind at the plumping race so the thing
that really allow us to do this type
really fast interactive queries is
really the data mention part that we
really very efficient one we didn't
really want to fill out all database
back-end but we really try on a number
of techniques like we try a sequel I we
try to post quest and I saw some
commercial database I show a little bit
later but as you look at a statistic
here right the post quest and sugilite
took almost like to rica by up this
space and the time to really index the
data like 13 hours for just one year and
you know but the real problem is that in
during the query performance when we
just do a very simple career performance
for like 1,000 you know trips in the
reserve sighs what happened trips
protect like three seconds already which
is really below our interactive speed we
want somewhere like order of seconds and
if we go a little larger it's take my 24
seconds so it's really slow and in order
to solve a problem in interactive
queries we do our all index you know our
all in memory database that have come
back revelations it's based on the KD
trees there's a lot more technically
tears I can point in the paper but
pretty much we reduce the size of the
database to 30 gigabyte and the building
timed half an hour why the query
performance is really much faster like
an order of magnitude faster based on
that pre military work we also have a
GPU based index which we're using
YouTube used to index these data and
it's now get to know two orders of
magnitude faster so for example we can
also compare him to a commercial
database out I don't want to name it the
name database but you can see it's like
almost two thousand times faster than
post crest or that commercial database
and our index was integrated into
MongoDB so it's not just like series
anymore we put index into MongoDB so we
can use for other apps no servers and
web servers and its really faster so the
question is why are these are to be a
mess so slow because there wasn't
designed for this purpose so actually
the spatial index is just some at on
that they add know later on like and
it's supposed to do for a small set of
data
not really for late sensors type later
like taxi and they only work with one no
one attributes and then we have two
attributes in taxi data and so they need
to join so under under dry you're going
to see the query planner for the owner
to statement so that's why they have it
shown on all the locations and then they
also join our destinations it's just a
lot of work and also there will be a lot
of point impala contest which means when
we travel regions we need to test if a
point really inside that regions and
that's also very expensive so there's
about six million tests for thirteen
thousand points so to wrap up with the
status of the taxi fees we demo at NYC
do t and toc they are currently using
our prototype and so this is this were
last year when we then wanted to answer
them the next time they come back and
say that it would truly blown away
because this is really the first time
they saw they saw this tie up to it was
it because they don't know about it
basis because of the they haven't really
get any good indexing out the data and
they always take time like I put the
they put the test there on the machine
in the come back in the next day or you
know half an hour later or they do you
really have to sample the data which you
will lose out all those events special
events give you simple data and now we
we have expanded this to a number of
different data types like you know
energy usage or real estate property
license etc and and we really want
improved a scary by using more larger
environments like running on the back
end of not hard to put more like an MPI
architecture for interactive and we
envision that this is a platform for our
no that's for urban jas see that and
this is there's another whole list of
the task we want to do with tech series
but if you look so this your screen
capture of our project management system
so this part is very important so we are
working on being a python bindings for
taxi fees that's because visual is not
always a way for for that the analyst to
do an asus right because after they do
data selection they light a selection
they want to run the same thing again
for all of the days right so now they
need a mechanism to do the batch jobs do
a scripting so so we need to be on tin
API with
some scripting of course Python so so
these two are on our task and we're
working on this we of course we know
actually looking for collaborations know
and suggestions on how to do this so
finally just to make to conclude this so
later expression especially in urban
environment is changing either small or
large data complexity and the key here
is that to be a tool that's really easy
for domain expert to use to really get
up into the loop of due date that
progressing and visualization is a
powerful tool because if you look at all
the plot for the macro and micro example
if there was no maps or no plot it's
really hard for you to see if there's
event missing in sick of you or not so
visualization is really play a key part
here which just have a sting I want to
say yeah and to do interactive
visualization it's really also more
challenging because you need to work
with data management part and finally we
want to adopt you know scripting Python
I still love Python so now we all if you
have any questions
yes so actually so actually we did this
we just download from that the chef is
online right so for example with zillow
they have a zeal that the chef fights
for all the neighborhood's is publicly
available yeah
yes arena is open to collaborators for
example like we did apply this at TLC do
t they have four sets of applications
the only reason that we didn't put it
get help like that because there's a lot
of small steps or either and saw up the
data that we use was not for data
because we interact with T or C before
they make the taxi data for so it was
some private stream of data as well but
we really you know we have no really try
hiding the short all is pretty open here
oh no so someone would it be doesn't
have real special index ray oh that's
interesting so we could test the things
that yes sir very good point so I think
at the time we didn't have that we try
yeah yeah because I which is the KD tree
not only for the special because we can
support the arbitrary number of
dimensions which mean like we also index
at the attributes not just that spatial
so we have spatial time and then the
tips fair of them in 12 dimensions yeah
thank you yes
yes so for example so since one our work
is due to the data so treaters we they
have special and time but a so have
keywords so our index I have a show here
but also work with keywords which mean
we try to transform the text into a
number and using the same infrastructure
for mapping the data so so it pretty
much a and the data shows that can
happen you know let's say in the
euclidean space which mean it has a
number can be indexing in this framework